[Music]
most people assume that experiments in
science are usually very expensive and
are very resource intensive however this
is not always true not all experiments
require many resources so let's talk
about the work of Alfred Hershey and
Martha Chase for example did you know
that the Hershey and the cheese
experiment was one of the most
remarkable works in the field of
genetics what was the experiment about
and what does it help us infer let's
find that out in the timeline of the
history of genetics that we looked at we
have reached this point so let's step
ahead and jump to the Year in 1952 to
American geneticists Alfred Hershey and
Martha Chase carried out a very simple
experiment that helped figure out
whether DNA was really the transforming
principle or not the experiment was
quite simple it just required a culture
medium two different radioactive
isotopes a mix a blender and a
centrifuge tube a culture medium is a
medium used to grow different kinds of
microorganisms with this equipment they
carried out an experiment using a
bacteriophage and a bacterial strain
let's find out how the experiment was
framed before that can you tell me what
bacteriophage is the term phage means
virus so the name bacteria phage stands
for virus that infects bacteria so
bacteria phages usually infect the host
bacterium by inserting their genetic
material into them and they make copies
of themselves using the replication
machinery of the host bacterium the
interesting thing here is that the body
of any bacteria phage is simply made up
of two components the outer protein coat
and the inner genetic material now let's
get back to the Hershey and chase
experiment the main aim of their
experiment was to
find out what exactly is the genetic
material is it proteins or DNA since the
phage contains only proteins and DNA
it's easier to find out which component
gets into the host bacterium they simply
used radio labeled markers to identify
the different strains so if the
bacterial cells have the radioactively
marked proteins in the end then it's the
proteins which are the genetic material
on the other hand if the radio labeled
DNA makes its way into the bacterial
cell then probably the DNA is the
genetic material so the experiment was
quite simple they first obtained radio
labeled bacteriophages one strain had
the radio labeled proteins and the other
had radio labeled DNA then they allowed
these different bacteria phages to
separately infect the bacteria and at
the end they analyzed the bacteria to
find out which radio labeled component
had made its way into it but how did
they obtain the radio labeled proteins
and DNA what was the process they used
and how are the results analyzed at the
end let's find out in the next part
Hershey and chase used bacteriophages
which are the viruses that infect the
bacteria we note that their bodies are
made up of only proteins and DNA that
makes it easier to figure out what gets
into the hosts bacterial cells the
experiment was quite simple they first
obtained radio labeled bacteriophages
there were two different types once with
radio labeled proteins and the others
with radio labeled DNA then they allowed
these different bacteria phages to
separately infect the bacteria and at
the end they analyzed the bacteria as to
which radio labels component had made
its way into it this is how the simple
experiment helped answer a few important
queries now let's get into the details
of this experiment and understand it
step by step the first thing Hershey and
chase did was that they obtained the
radio labeled fate strains in one
nutrient medium they added the radio
isotope sulfur 35 which is s 35 in the
other they added phosphorous 32 which is
P 32 but why only sulfur and phosphorus
and that too in separate mediums well
sulfur is an integral part of proteins
but it's not present in the DNA on the
other hat phosphorus is present in the
DNA but not in the proteins does for
easy analysis they chose the radio
isotopes of these two elements so one
nutrient medium was added with the
sulfur 35 radio isotope the bacteria
grown in this medium does had s35
incorporated into their bodies now what
will happen if the bacteria phages are
allowed to infect these bacteria it's
obvious that s35 will get incorporated
in the protein coats of these bacteria
phages as well that is because these are
derived from the body of these host
bacteria so the first batch of
s35 labeled bacteriophages was ready
similarly in this culture medium
they added p32 and allowed the growth of
bacterial colonies as a result all the
bacteria phages obtained post infection
had radio labeled DNA so the second
batch of bacteriophages with radio
labeled DNA was also ready with them now
all they had to do is allow these
radioactively marked bacteriophages to
infect new bacterial cells these host
cells will be the ones harboring the new
phage generations which will help
analyze what has passed down the line so
they infected the bacterial cells with
the two batches separately after several
hours of infection the cultures were
agitated in a mixer blender why is the
step necessary it is needed to make sure
that post infection the empty phage
coats get separated from the bacterial
cells the agitation helps release the
empty phage coats attached to the
bacterial cells now in the next step
they centrifuge the culture at an
extremely high speed centrifugal process
works on the principle of gravitational
force so when the sample is centrifuged
at a very high speed the heavier denser
particles settle at the bottom while the
lighter particles remain on top what is
settled at the bottom is usually called
pellet while the one that floats on top
is called supernatant
so the centrifugation step helped
Hershey and chase to obtain two layers
the one on top was supernatant and the
one at the bottom was pellet they
checked the radioactivity in both the
batches and concluded their analysis
before we reach the conclusions
can you help Nora guess the
interpretation what will be the
interpretation if the radioactivity is
found in the supernatant and what will
be the inference if it's found in the
think about it let me help you with this
the supernatant contains phage ghosts
which are the empty shells or coats of
phage it does not have the replicated
next generations of the bacteria phages
similarly the pellet will contain the
bacterial cells and the newer phage
particles so now in case one if the
radioactivity is observed in the
supernatant then it means that the
marker is only present in the protein
coat of the phage and did not get into
the bacterial cells this can help us
conclude that the proteins are not the
genetic material as the newly formed
phage particles did not receive s35 on
the other hand if the radioactivity is
seemed in the pellet then it would mean
that the newer phage cells have all got
the radioactive p32
in them does the DNA in the form of
genetic material has successfully got
transformed into the new phage particles
this is what the analysis of both the
cases can be now let's look at the
results Hershey and cheese obtained on
analyzing the first sample they found
that the radioactivity was present in
the supernatant and in the second batch
the radioactivity was found in the
pellet what did this mean that's right
with this the two concluded that it's
the DNA which is the genetic material
and not the proteins if proteins would
have been the genetic material then the
pellet in the first batch would have
shown the presence of radioactive s35
instead the pellet in the second batch
showed the presence of p32 does it was
confirmed that it's the DNA which is the
genetic material with this avery MacLeod
and McCarty's analysis that Griffiths
transforming principle was DNA was also
proved does the long ignored DNA
molecule
now rose to fame and scientists all over
the globe started working on finding its
structure but how was the structure
discovered and what does the actual
structure of a DNA molecule look like
let's find that out in the next part
[Music]